I'd like to start today's video with a
question will history rate george w bush
as the worst president ever at least
half of americans thought so a decade
ago during his presidency his approval
ratings absolutely soared after the
worst terrorist attack ever on American
soil
then they bottoms out near the end of
his term as the conflict in the Middle
East trudged on a president's son with
all of the privilege in the world he was
a party boy in his youth and he was
never expected to go into politics so
what made him follow in his father's
footsteps and well what is he up to
today so in the video today we're gonna
dive into the life of America's 43rd
president george w bush
[Music]
George Walker Bush was the first of six
children born to George HW Bush and
Barbara Pierce Bush on July the 6th 1946
in New Haven Connecticut the Bush family
they were well off theirs was a
prominent northeastern banking family
and later a political dynasty at the
time of Bush's birth his father George
senior was an undergraduate students at
Yale University immediately after
graduating in 1948 George senior broke
with family tradition and moved his
young family to the boom towns of West
Texas to try his luck in oil but at
their first apartment in Odessa the
bushes had to share a bathroom with
neighboring prostitutes in 1950 though
the family settled in Midland Texas once
referred to as the headquarters of the
independent oilman at the time 215 oil
companies had offices there Bush Senior
would eventually earn a fortune in the
oil business making millions by the time
he was only 40 years old the first
family home in Midland was in a
development nicknamed Easter egg row for
its tiny colorful houses as the Bush
family grew however they needed more
space so they moved to a larger home on
a high o Avenue in 1951 George II as he
was often called was only five years old
at the time
today Bush's childhood home is listed on
the National Register of Historic Places
and is open to the public
six days a week Bush II enjoyed an
idyllic baby boomer childhood growing up
in West Texas the neighborhood it was
safe it was full of young families he
played baseball idolizing the great
Willie Mays and developed friendships
that remained throughout his entire life
the Sam Houston elementary school was
not far from his house in 1953 though
tragedy struck the Bush family when
three year old Pauline Robin was
diagnosed with a strange disease near
the Barbara roared George senior had
heard of before and that disease was
leukemia despite their best efforts
taking her far from home for treatment
in New York sloan-kettering cancer
center Robin died just seven months
after her diagnosis George jr. was seven
and had not known his sister's grave
condition after her death his parents
picked him up from school in the big
green Oldsmobile he recalled years later
being positive that he saw his sister in
the backseat upon seeing her he was
excited and he ran up to the car to see
her when his parents broke the news he
understood that she was gone and it
changed their lives forever
some say the loss of Robin was the
impetus for the deep mother-son bond the
George Jr and Barb reformed they both
spent a great deal of time together
after her death eventually the Bush
family added three more children to the
clan including Neil in 1955 Marvin in
1956 and another daughter Dorothy in
1959 that same year with George seniors
success in the oil business the bushes
relocated to Houston in 1960 the 14 year
old Bush was sent away to attends the
exclusive all-boys boarding school
Phillips Academy in Andover
Massachusetts yeah he lived in the
shadow of his more successful and
luminous father for a fun-loving Texan
Phillips it was a drastic change the
curriculum was rigorous the environments
was ultra structured and it was cold
bush
it was pretty envious of his buddies
back home they were able to do things
like take their girlfriends out on a
Friday night date so with no social life
to speak of Bush he played sports
instead now academics they did not come
easily for Bush he received a zero on
his first written assignment and I
wanting to fail Bush spent many nights
Phillips Academy after curfew
studying by the light that seeped under
his door he developed a love of American
history during his high school years and
said later that he would bloom where he
was planted in his a dull life Bush
acknowledged receiving a first-rate
education of Phillips in 1964 when it
was time to go off to college Bush chose
his father's and his grandfather's alma
mater Yale University during his
freshman year his father decided to run
for Texas Senate and called upon his son
for help
Bush jr. worked on the campaign doing
what he could from Connecticut the elder
Bush well he lost the campaign but it
did prove to be a valuable first time
learning experience for George Jr while
at Yale Bush had a bit of a reputation
for being a goodtime sky he excelled
socially like he always has and he
struggled with his studies he was
students he also wanted to play baseball
but quickly found out that rugby
actually suited him better he paid the
position of fullback in his first year
Bush joins the fraternity Delta Kappa
Epsilon or DKE
and eventually he became its president
it was in his junior year that he was
tapped for introduction into Yale's
premier secret society skull and bones
he was the third Bush together with his
father and his grandfather to be
indicted
now conspiracy theories have attempted
to link this secret group to the CIA the
Illuminati even the Nazis and even to
this day Bush himself he remains
tight-lipped about his involvement as a
Bonesmen either way Bush graduated with
a Bachelor of Arts degree from Yale in
1968 this was the very same year the
Martin Luther King jr. and JFK were
assassinated and the war in Vietnam was
raging in May of 1968 Bush was
commissioned into the Texas Air National
Guard after two years of training an
active duty service he was assigned to
Houston flying convair f-102 s with the
147th reconnaissance wing out of the
Ellington field joint reserve base now
during his presidential campaign in 2004
critics of Bush included Democratic
National Committee Chairman Terry
McAuliffe accused him of receiving
preferential treatment while in the
service and of being absent without
leave
AWOL from 1972 to 1973 following the
controversy the Department of Defense
released all records related to Bush's
Texas Air National Guard service in June
of 2005 according to his released
records Bush never flew in the Air
National Guard off to April of 1972 his
pilot's license had been revoked for
failure to undergo the mandatory
physical examination in 1972 Bush was
living in Montgomery Alabama and working
on the US Senate campaign of Republican
Wynton M Blount while in Alabama he
drilled with the 187th Fighter Wing of
the Air National Guard Bush was
honorably discharged on November the
21st 1974 now in 1973 Bush entered
Harvard Business School and graduated
with an MBA in 1975 then soon after in
1977 he began
his industry career in Texas oil
establishing our busto energy with a
number of other private investors
operations began the following year in
now Bush was not as successful in the
oil business and his father and he sold
our busto in 1984 to spectrum 7 another
Texas gas exploration firm he remains
the CEO of this business under the terms
of the sale in 1986 spectrum 7th merged
with harken Energy Corporation where
Bush held a seat on the board of
directors and retains an annual
consulting contract then sometime later
in 1988 which was working on his
father's bid to become the next
president of the United States it was at
this point that he learned his father's
friend and fellow oilman Eddie Giles was
selling the Texas Rangers baseball
franchise not wanting to see this
opportunity slip by Bush organized a
syndicate to purchase a controlling
interest in the team at a reported 89
million dollars Bush became the general
manager of this team even though his
initial investment was only half a
million dollars
indeed Bush even took out a loan to pay
for his share it was in 1990 the bush
sold his Harkins stock to pay the
balance of the loan off that had taken
out to purchase the Rangers two months
after the sale however Harkin released
its quarterly numbers showing a larger
than expected loss unsurprisingly
insider trading allegations erupted and
the sale of Bush's stock was
investigated by the US Securities and
Exchange Commission who ultimately found
no wrongdoing
[Music]
in 1977 Bush was invited to barbecue at
his friend's house in Texas the only
other guest was a woman Bush had never
met even though she was from Midland too
Bush was enamored with the beautiful
teacher and librarian Laura Lane Welch
and the two fell in love almost
instantly
it was a short whirlwind romance before
they were Wed three months later on
November the 5th 1977 the couple settled
in Midland and in 1981 the couple had
fraternal twin daughters Jenna and
Barbara Bush credits his wife Laura with
bringing his own life into order as a
young man he was aimless with periods of
unemployment he drank too much and he
really enjoyed going out at I mean he
refers to you as his nomadic period one
embarrassing episode came back to haunt
him years later on the campaign trail in
2000 at the age of 30 while on vacation
in Maine at the family's summer
residence he was arrested for drunk
driving Bush kept the matter private
until the story broke in the news media
when asked about it he responded I
oftentimes said that years ago I made
some mistakes I occasionally drank too
much and ideas on that night I regret
that it happens but it did I've learned
my lesson so after his marriage to Laura
Bush he joins the United Methodist
Church and became a born-again Christian
the day after is 40th birthday on July
the 6th 1986 Bush gave up drinking
alcohol for good
[Music]
Bush decided to run for the governor of
Texas as a Republican after his father
failed to win the presidential
re-election in 1992 as manager for the
Texas Rangers Bush had earned a
reputation as a savvy businessman and he
was well-liked in his home state his
campaign against the Democrat Ann
Richards focused on welfare and tort
reform reducing crime and improving
education the richards camp was sure the
bush would make a gaffe or lose his
temper on the campaign trail but he
never did it was a close race and it was
a contentious one Bush eventually won
the election with 53 percent of the vote
and was sworn in as the 46th governor of
Texas in 1995 he became the first child
of a u.s. president to be elected as a
state governor in 1998 he was re-elected
with 69 percent of the vote and became
the first governor in Texas history to
be elected to serve two consecutive
four-year terms as governor Bush was
left with a budget surplus which he used
to push a two billion dollar tax cut
plan to reduce property taxes and
increase funding for education reform
the tax cut was the largest in Texas
history and to pay for it he sought the
federal government's approval to
privatize social services two other
notable pieces of legislation he signed
into law included the lowering of the
age of which juveniles could be tried as
adults in criminal cases and a
requirement of electric retailers to buy
a portion of energy from renewable
sources
eventually Texas became the largest
producer of wind powered electricity in
the United States in his second term
Bush promoted faith-based organizations
and proclaimed June the 10th 2000 Jesus
Day in Texas this was a day in which he
urged all Texans do answer the call to
serve those in need now a criticism of
his time in office was the fact that
under his leadership Texas executed 152
prisoners at the time it was more than
any other Texas governor
but overall Bush had a reputation for
working well across the aisle in a
non-confrontational way and they sent
him a great deal of respect throughout
his first term and after his successful
and easy reelection many were
speculating whether Bush would make a
bid for the White House
[Music]
On June the 14th of 1999 Bush formally
announced his candidacy for the
Republican presidential nomination he
stated I'm running because our country
must be prosperous but prosperity must
have a purpose the purpose of Prosperity
is to make sure the American Dream
touches every willing heart the purpose
of Prosperity is to leave no one out to
leave no one behind
I'm running because my party must match
a conservative minds with a
compassionate heart and I'm running to
win during the early part of the 2000
presidential campaign Bush enjoyed a
double-digit lead in the polls over his
opponent Vice President Al Gore jr. as
the election approached the gap narrowed
and Gore beat out bush in the popular
vote by 540 3895 votes with the deciding
votes hanging on Florida the race was
determined to be too close to call by
major news networks after first
proclaiming Gore the winner the margin
was so close that it spurred a recount
in some counties as lawsuits made their
way through the courts the final
election count was Bush with 271 and
Gore with 266 to this day only 5
presidents have lost the popular vote
and won the election Bush was sworn in
as America's 43rd president On January
the 20th 2001 for the second time in
history they son of a former president
had made it to the White House the first
by the way that was John Quincy Adams he
was elected in 1824 his father was John
Adams the second president ever Bush's
new administration it was focused on
compassionate conservatism this embraced
excellence in education tax relief and
volunteerism among faith-based and
community organizations it wasn't long
before his focus drastically shifted as
he was faced with the greatest challenge
of any presidents since Abraham Lincoln
on the morning of September the 11th
2001 19 men trained by Al Qaeda carried
out a coordinated attack on the United
States hijacking for large passenger
airplanes with the intention of crashing
them into major landmarks three of the
four planes hit their targets the north
and south towers the Twin Towers of the
World Trade Center and the
Pentagon in Arlington Virginia the
fourth plane crashed into a field in
rural Pennsylvania in a single day these
deliberate acts of mass murder kills
nearly 3,000 people 400 of which were
first responders as these attacks were
happening President Bush sat in a
classroom at the Emory Booker Elementary
School in Sarasota County Florida with
children he was reading the pet goat
White House chief of staff Andrew card
whispered in his ear informing him the
second plane hit the World Trade Center
what President Bush did next was
possibly one of the most controversial
decisions of his presidency he stayed in
the classroom for seven more minutes
following along with the students
reading before excusing himself he was
brief since gave a short press
conference while at the school before
being taken to a secure location in
order to board Air Force One Michael
Moore in his film Fahrenheit 9/11 was
highly critical of Bush's seven minutes
of inaction in the classroom Moore
claims that it indicated the bush was
indecisive on the other hand his
defenders made the case for keeping the
children calm saying that it was Bush's
most important duty at the time from the
White House on the evening of 9/11 he
spoke to Americans with resolve to fight
terrorism and stand together as a nation
America and our friends and allies
joined with all those who want peace and
security in the world and we stand
together to win the war against
terrorism tonight I ask for your prayers
for all those who grieve for the
children whose words have been shattered
for all whose sense of safety and
security has been threatened and I pray
they will be comforted by a Power
greater than any of us spoken through
the ages in Psalm 23 even though I walk
through the valley of the shadow of
death I fear no evil for you are with me
in response to the terrorist attacks of
9/11 Bush declared a war on terrorism
and formed a new cabinet-level
Department of Homeland Security he sent
American forces into Afghanistan to
break up the Taliban an extremist group
under Osama bin Laden that trained
financed and exported terrorist teams
the Taliban was disrupted but bin Laden
was not found until much later following
the attacks President Bush also recast
the nation's intelligence gathering and
analysis services and ordered reform of
military forces in order to meet a new
enemy at the same time is doing all of
this he had other political promises to
keep and delivered
a major tax cut now Bush's most
controversial act was the invasion of
Iraq on the belief that Iraqi president
Saddam Hussein posed a grave threat to
the United States by possessing weapons
of mass destruction the weapons though
they were never found
Saddam was captured that many American
servicemen and friendly Iraqis lost
their lives during the conflict in his
State of the Union address in 2005 Bush
pledged that the US would help the Iraqi
people establish a fully democratic
government bringing hopes of the region
and lift a threat from the lives of
future generations Bush he left office
with an abysmal 33 percent approval
rating but despite this Bush's political
adviser Karl Rove said that Bush has an
inner confidence that what he did was
right
[Music]
after he left Washington DC Bush and his
wife Laura returned to Midlands and
promptly took up residence at the
Prairie Chapel ranch in Crawford Texas
then they also bought a house in Dallas
and became part of the community
unlike some former presidents Bush seems
to enjoy the rest and relaxation of
being out of office he golfs has taken
up painting attracting national
attention and attends Texas Rangers
baseball games
he's also heavily involved in the local
community he occasionally gives speeches
and was very involved in the George W
Bush Institute that he established at
Southern Methodist University he said
once I think parts of having a
fulfilling life is to be challenged I'm
challenged on the golf course I'm
challenged to stay fit and I'm
challenged by my paintings I am happy so
I really hope you enjoyed that episode
of biographic if you did there's a
couple of things you could do right now
one is hit that like button below also
if you want more stuff like this we put
out brand new videos every Monday and
every Thursday so hit that subscribe
button below and subscribe button
doesn't do what it used to on YouTube if
you actually want to get a notification
about these videos please do hit that
Bell button next to the subscribe button
and that'll send you a notification
every time every Monday and Thursday
won't put out a new video also if you
want to watch something else right now
stuff from the archive over there on the
right and as always thank you for
watching
[Music]
you